so another Valentine's Day been and gone
did he get up too much I spent the
entire weekend in bed at a migraine I
vomited everywhere but when nothing was
coming up it made me think what if sex
worked the same way it does it's easier
to predict when you're going to get laid
in a video game compared to real life
because you can you know Google how to
get to the endgame but in both games and
real life there's more to it than just
pressing X to sex in order to get your
digital end away that's disgusting
dating sims focus on the basics like the
fine art of conversation you make a
splash being the new kid or bird in town
before you know it you're surrounded by
birds sometimes it's enough to just talk
about your favorite foods sports or
alien conspiracy theories and as long as
you don't wet yourself then BAM you're
sure to be a pixelated sweaty mess in no
time and while being a bonafide beefcake
is also sure to get you laid most of the
time you've got to use your sexiest
organ the spleen the brain to get into
the pants of your beloved a grand
gesture like getting them a gift taking
them out on a date even bowling
especially bowling and engaging with
their favorite subjects is sure to get
you closer to your Intendant love works
in mysterious ways but in any case the
brain is a key player in the game of
seduction
please stop you sound like the host of a
dating show well maybe I am sometimes
it's not about who you are but the
circumstances you find yourself in that
make you more attractive to your
would-be player to two people thrown
together in the midst of chaotic bullets
praying shenanigans frequently seem to
end up together and just take your
average end of the world scenario you're
gonna die you might as well
hooray for war babies Nazi takeovers
giant demon spewing holes in the sky and
the impending end of the universe
seems to make people friskier that a
squid on Tuesday if all else fails
remember you can just pay your way and
then watch it in first person and while
video games may make the buildups
getting laid look easy remember to try
and be passionate while you're there
here's looking at you Fifty Shades of
cage
I hear women like men who blink and you
know always remember to take your pants
off because sex is pretty hard if you
don't let's watch
so sexing games is like really weird huh
yeah especially when developers give you
an achievement for doing it like a
virtual high five anyway did you least
get any card this year my mom used to
send them to me from my cat until he
died yeah your mom used to send them to
me too
Oh from my cat nope
you